now on to our next block pun intended of
course minecraft legends is the action
strategy take on the franchise you never
knew you needed i'm here with dennis
reese from mojang studios who has just
released the world premiere trailer of
minecraft legends dennis welcome to the
show thanks for having me so happy to
have you i mean this is a really
exciting time for the team let's talk
minecraft as a whole though that game i
have nothing to back this up but i feel
like everyone on the planet's played
minecraft at this point um but that
wasn't enough for you all you all went
and made minecraft dungeons and now
we're moving on to the recently revealed
minecraft legends so one tell me a
little bit about what it means for the
team to actually be able to reveal the
game and then two just let us know what
minecraft legends is uh well we are so
excited to finally be able to talk about
this game with the world we've been
working on this game for some time now
minecraft legends is an action strategy
game is set in the minecraft universe
and in order to build this we really
wanted to partner with a great company
that understands strategy games and so
that's when we reached out with
blackbird interactive
and
in doing so we were able to create an
experience
that is uh welcoming for you know people
who may have not played minecraft but
also people who have
and i mean you've seen the trailer it's
about going and traveling through these
beautiful biomes
exploring this world that is familiar
yet still mysterious and so as you
explore these lush biomes you collect
resources and then you use those
resources to to build defenses from
these dangerous but very cute piglens
and uh in those offensive you're able to
to fight them back and send them back to
where they come from and you know what
you're
going to probably want to build some
alliances with some unexpected friends
because they're going to help you
actually defeat the piglets and send
them back to where they come from i'm
looking forward to it and i feel i love
what you said about
trying to make a game that's both for
fans of minecraft that exist and new
fans coming in minecraft can go in so
many different directions i feel like
with a new game what made you choose
action strategy well really it was a you
know many years ago as a group of folks
at mojang sitting around talking about
what game genres they really enjoy and
action and strategy were
the most popular ones that came up and
so we started to think about who we
could partner with to build that
experience and that's where we we came
into blackberry interactive and that was
back in 2018
and you know the project was codenamed
badger
and uh an interesting little fact for
many of those people that
might follow minecraft if you go back to
minecon 2018
and you look at the shirt that jens
berenstein was wearing you'll see a
graphic on there and it's in the shape
of a badger head and really that was
meant to be an easter egg for years for
forward which here we are now and that's
i gotta say i love a good easter egg um
now where would you say that minecraft
legends fits in the overall minecraft
universe well the minecraft universe is
just always growing and expanding and if
it's not from our partner communities
and it's from mojang specifically like
you mentioned uh minecraft dungeons
that's a great example where mojang went
out and we built this dungeon crawler
experience in the minecraft universe and
players love it it's wonderful and with
minecraft legends we're trying to do
something similar really and here we're
going to be introducing a narratively
driven campaign with a whole bunch of
new characters and a lot of other things
that i'm not ready to share right now uh
dennis i thought we were friends i
thought we were friends you can share it
with me and everyone watching
no okay i won't pry any anymore but tell
us when the game is coming out and where
we can keep up to date it's coming out
in 2023 on pc and console on xbox game
pass
and if you want to know more just follow
us twitter or you know jump on
minecraft.net uh dennis i'm so excited
to jump into minecraft legends thank you
so much for stopping by and giving us
the lowdown oh thanks for having me
you